hi there Steve here today I want to ask
you people my listeners and viewers a
question I find that in different
languages there are certain things that
I want to say in a language that I'm
learning that give me trouble for
example you know with the Korean I found
that it was difficult for me to use the
future tense for some reason I have
trouble I had trouble with the future
tense I had trouble with sort of saying
things like you know as in japan uu n
sometimes you say saw the show like in
French n'est pas wouldn't you agree
there's that sort of looking for an echo
of confirmation that we use when
speaking and I couldn't get that in in
Korean because I was confusing it with
Japanese maybe in the romance languages
it's often certain verb endings that
give me trouble like it might be you
know the third person singular of the of
the simple past or something like that
in Russian obviously it's verbs of
motion or aspects of verbs case n DS but
sometimes it's just wanting to say
something like how sometimes the you
know it's very I find it very important
in the language to get a real solid grip
on why because therefore in order to
because we build a lot of our discussion
around around those concepts how to ask
questions and and I've often felt that
some of these things some of these
concepts that we want to express in
different languages are in a way coming
to all languages and so that this is
kind of their the basic patterns in a
language or maybe 20 30 40 basic
patterns and I'm just curious to hear
from you what are the patterns concept
aspects of the language or languages
that you're learning that give you the
most trouble alright I'll be very
interested to hear just put a little
comment here underneath my my video
alright that's all I have today thanks
for listening bye for now
[Music]